so it's official Christopher Nolan is
finally giving us bird scraps of
information on his next Batman movie and
here's what he's given us officially the
title is the Dark Knight Rises and I've
heard mixed things about the title I
mean some people think the title is okay
some people hate the title nobody really
loves the title I personally have no
problem with the title probably because
I couldn't think of I mean I personally
wouldn't be able to come up with a title
it's better than the Dark Knight Rises I
mean can't be the Dark Knight Returns
because that takes people back to Batman
Returns you can't do nightfall if that's
not what he's doing and there are things
to consider like I'm sure the studio was
like Christopher Nolan thank you for
coming back you're the best thank you
for doing the third Batman means the
world to us um that being said you do
have to have the title V Dark Knight
somewhere and in the Dark Knight sequel
somewhere somehow the words the dark and
I'd have to be in sequence glad you're
back
so it might have been a studio call at
that point who knows so the title it's
okay but when Heath Ledger was cast as
the Joker everyone was like lame and I
seriously can you honestly say that he
sucked in the role at this point I mean
the closer it comes to the release of
the movie I mean everyone's gonna be
more and more on board with it I mean
we're all gonna have Dark Knight Rises
t-shirts at that but I mean bitching
about it right now just doesn't really
matter Tom Hardy's gonna be in it from
you know you remember him from inception
he's only really revealed the villains
that aren't going to be in the movie he
said there will be no mr. freeze and
there will be no Riddler which I'm not
gonna lie I was kind of shocked about
that I thought I totally called that I
thought the Riddler was going to be the
villain and third one I guess not that
Nolan man he keeps us guessing so if
he's not doing the Riddler I'm thinking
he might go a more unconventional route
you know like hush or black mask and the
Dark Knight Rises will not be in 3d more
IMAX yeah but not 3d it's pretty much
why Nolan's awesome but I'm more
interested in hearing what you guys
think about this what do you think of
the Dark Knight Rises title who do you
think Tom Hardy's gonna play in the
movie I've actually heard a rumor that
he might play a Harvey Bullock the fat
cop who hates Batman which no I just
don't see him as fat cop watch this
exactly who he's gonna be now and well I
would look like a who do you
think the main villains gonna be I'm
calling black mask err hush either of
those two comment below let me know what
you guys think and if this is the first
video of mine that you've seen if you
like what you've seen here and you want
see more than click right here to see
more
[Music]